deploying the time came in operation has
taken time we've been working since
about five years with the organizing
committee we are bringing 220 tons of
equipment it's a team of over 250 people
professionals coming from different
countries together with over 400
volunteers that join us for the
competition so 650 people in total will
operate this whole operation for
Vancouver we are having some certain
number of new elements like for any
Olympians you are having a new starting
yet at the ski alpine skiing and the
particularity of the starting is that it
can work without power because we use
the energy that the skier puts in the
opening of the gate to activate a
generator that will give enough energy
to get the contact and the pulse for the
exact timing of the departure we will
use gps in cross country competitions so
that we take the position of each
competitor five times per second and
knowing this you can easily calculate
the speed the difference of distance or
difference of speed between athletes
which may make the competition much more
appealing and understandable for
spectators and for TV viewers in figure
skating we'll have a new HD video replay
system because you know that it's very
important that at this level of
competition the judges can see without
any doubt all the small details of the
performance of the competitors and this
is something new that we have developed
along the last year's winter is always a
challenge outdoor we did yesterday
the first official training in alpine
skiing from M competition had 40 skiers
then has been stopped our people have
the Stargate spend eight hours waiting
in the snow outside in bad weather
conditions this is a challenge but our
people are trained for this all our
equipment I are built to go at
temperature and to still work at
temperatures that goes up to minus 30
degrees so we should be fine for this
Olympic Games ski jumping is composed of
two parts the measurement of the length
of the journey itself and a certain
number of scoring that are given by the
judges evaluating the quality of life of
the landing for the measurement we are
using cameras that are spread along the
landing area and with the image analysis
system we can find with the precision of
about 20 centimeters the exact point
where the jumper has touched the ground
and the results of the competition by
rules of the Federation have to be given
with the precision of half a meter so we
are far and the necessary precision
that's imposed by the rules of the
National Federation
you